Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's March 28, 2023.
We're here in Active Bookstream number
1.012.
Off to you, Bleu.
Bleu: Great.
So we will be continuing our discussion
of the book governing Continuous
Transformation by Bijean Kesri and this
actually is going to wrap up our coverage
of this book.
We're not going to go into the interviews
covered in the final section, but we're
going to just cover this concluding part
and then wrap it up now.
And then in a few weeks we will rejoin
for a discussion section or a discussion
session.
So if you've been following along with
the live streams to this point, please
get in touch with us so that you can come
on and discuss some of the contents of
the book with us.
And hopefully the author is available to
join us.
So we are Active Inference Lab Institute,
a participatory online institute that is
communicating, learning and practicing
applied active inference.
You can reach us at social media at all
of these links.
This is also a recorded and an archived
Livestream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we will be attempting to
follow good video etiquette for live
streams.
Again, there's many ways to participate
and collaborate with the Active Inference
Institute.
So if you are interested Active Inference
Lab and are not yet collaborating with
us, just get in touch.
Active Inference is our website and
there's a link to fill out a form if you
want to contribute in other ways to the
institute besides joining us on the live
stream.
So the goal of this bookstream is to
conclude our discussions of this book.
So we are going to cover chapters twelve
and 13.
I want to skip to the road belt.
So we're going to cover chapters twelve
and 13 in this part three conclusion of
the book.
So chapter twelve is the future Research
agenda and chapter 13 is outperformance
and survival as a matter of self
organization.
So we can just quickly introduce
ourselves before jumping into the
contents.
I'm Bleu.
I'm an independent research consultant in
New Mexico, and I'll pass it off to
Tyler.
Tyler: I'm Tyler.
I'm a protocol designer and Dow
researcher.
Also in California.
Daniel: And Daniel I'm a researcher in
California.
Bleu: Did I say California?
I meant to say New Mexico.
I think I said, did I say California?
Oh, my gosh.
All california.
Tyler: I'm probably getting confused.
Bleu: Maybe I said California.
I'm having visions of the beach.
Okay, so chapter twelve has a few
different sections.
Again, this is like future research
directions.
The Jeans discusses language and
communication, embodied cognition,
artificial intelligence, board
capabilities, developmental paths, and
then chapter 13 is really just a
provocative conclusion section and
reminds us of some of the things that
we've learned in the book so far and also
outperformance and survival as a matter
of like free energy minimization.
So we will jump right into the content
tyler, do you want to read this first
part of the abstract for us?
Sure.
Tyler: Feg is the product of the
multidisciplinary research project
connecting the dots among strategy
governance and neuroscience research.
Opening a new conversation headlines
introducing the free energy principles
strategy management feg redefines the
nexus structure of cognition ABV so
touching base view advances the dynamic
capability view and from the managerial
to the core level and establishes
strategy as an inactive Bayesian
inference challenge.
In terms of future research, four areas
should advance the optimization of Feg
one, language and communication.
In particular, explainability of
corporate purpose prediction models and
predictions.
Two, by cognition in terms of a deeper
understanding around the neurobiology
underlying leadership's world engagement
as well as false inference.
Bleu: Thanks, and I'll read this next
part.
So the third area is artificial
intelligence, in particular the strategy
application of Aipowered machine
algorithms and fourth, board capabilities
developmental paths, in particular, the
board's ability to collectively develop
meta capabilities.
Free Energy Governance as a framework
provides the fundamental building blocks
that empower a firm to implement free
energy minimization as a self organized
principle structure top down bottom up
connectivity, cognition, environmental
enactment and capabilities duality
Management within the SDG framework, many
vibrant strategy research topics lend
themselves to be repurposed as a matter
of optimizing free energy minimization.
More specifically, survival rather than
just performance is the critical
dependent variable.
Sorry, I'm trying to navigate my board so
getting into the first section, Language
and Communication.
So I just pulled a couple of sentences
out of this section.
Bijean says that the effectiveness of
free energy governance is critically
determined by transparency in
communication, specifically around the
explainability of corporate purpose
prediction models and predictions to
obtain the most possible human energy for
productive effort.
And I think this is really something.
The communication overall is an area that
I would like to discuss with Bijean
further.
But he does really kind of clarify some
of the questions that we've been having
over the last couple of weeks here in
this section, and even maybe the next
section about what specifically needs to
be communicated to all members of the
firm and at all levels.
So he really does kind of clarify.
He says if organization is emergent in
communication as we believe, then it is
not a being but a becoming.
And that's a quote from Taylor 2000.
And then he also says language is not a
tool, but a force.
And with this, I think he specifically is
referring to a force that holds the firm
together, contributes to the self
organizing purpose and sustainability of
the firm.
And really he does talk a lot about the
purpose of the firm both in this chapter
and the next, as like, everybody needs to
know what is the point for the firm's
existence or for the corporation's
existence?
And so I think that that is one aspect
that might not necessarily be like a
governance strategy or something that's
internal, like a method of operation
that's like we think about the top level
executives, but something that why are we
here?
What are we doing?
What purpose are we serving as a
corporation, as a company?
And I think that that is like one
reasonable thing that can be communicated
to team members at all levels.
I don't know if you guys have any
thoughts here or.
Tyler: Yeah, one thing that was not
really clear on about what John was
getting at here was what it means to have
explainable purpose.
Because on one level, the feg, like
ultimate purpose, as I understand it, is
just like survival.
But I'm not sure if he meant purpose in
some other sense of like, I don't know,
we are improving our customers access to
health care or something like that style
level of purpose.
And I wasn't quite clear what he meant
and he didn't quite give that many
examples.
So I'm not sure if you guys have any
thoughts or a clear sense of what he
meant.
Daniel: Yeah, very good question.
It does seem to be like there's competing
Communications around.
What purpose is is purpose in this
deflationary sense merely survival and
persistence, at which point the clear
communication would just be around
whatever we are, we need to continue,
even if that involves change versus more
sub purposes or topical performances,
which then might resemble standard non
survival oriented purposes.
Like to deliver the most x in y.
Tyler: Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Bleu: So I would question also if
survival is the purpose of free energy
governance or if free energy minimization
is the purpose.
I think about when a firm swallows
another firm in MNA, right?
But then the little firm is not the
purpose is not to survive, right?
Like the purpose is to become amalgamated
or whatever subsumed by the larger
corporation.
Sorry if I cut you off or interrupted
your thought.
Tyler: Yeah, I guess something that I
feel like has been not maybe I just
haven't gotten it, but not necessarily
consistently communicated is whether
purpose is at the highest level of
organization or at sub levels.
So in the same way as a pancreas cell may
not know the metapurpose of the pancreas,
I don't know anything about biology, so
I'm not misstating something here.
Is it necessarily true that an individual
team has to always keep in mind the
larger metapurpose of this organization?
Or is it really okay to have something
that's more relevant to its subunit
organization?
And that hasn't always been clear to me.
I'm still kind of struggling with that.
Bleu: Yeah.
I do think that Bajan specifically when
he was talking about purpose, and I think
that it comes more in the next chapter,
but it might have been this chapter.
I don't know.
It's all blurring together, this one big
chapter.
But he talks about purpose being on the
front lines, right?
Like the people that are on the front
lines are as much determining the purpose
as they are communicating the purpose.
So it might be not a top down directional
communication method.
It's a reciprocal communicating.
The purpose of the organization is
probably like a bi directional
information flow, ideally, anyway.
So people at the top don't know what the
people at the bottom think the purpose
is, and the people at the bottom don't
know what the people at the top think the
purpose is.
There's no unity, and then the firm has a
divided purpose, I guess.
Tyler: Yeah, I think that makes sense.
I mean, my take on what he's saying is
it's like this co created maybe amorphous
thing that you're not necessarily pinning
down and defining and putting on a
landing page on your website.
Maybe it's something that's more of like
a shared, felt and sensed thing.
That's what I think he's saying, but he
doesn't explain it that way, so I'm not
totally sure.
Bleu: Yeah, so these are good questions
that we will, I think, hopefully have the
opportunity to discuss further.
For sure.
Okay.
Unless there's anything else.
We'll go to embodied cognition, where he
says brain, body and environment together
form one integrated, cognitive embodied,
inactive extended system recasting the
phenomena of false inference and
institutional psychosis as a matter of
impaired prediction.
Error minimization may highlight how
critically firm performance is also a
function of upper echelon's embodied
cognition as determined amongst other by
psychological aspects as well as
neurobiology.
So in this section, there was a whole
bunch of neuroscience about dopamine and
the reward system and prediction error
minimization.
And obviously, a firm doesn't have
dopamine as a prediction error satisfier
or reward, but they do.
The whole firm isn't getting like a
dopamine hit, but the individual members
within that firm are getting that
dopamine, I guess, when their predictions
are correct.
Yeah, this was kind of like a big stretch
for me to jump into, I guess.
The embodied cognition of the firm is the
embodied cognition of the upper echelon.
But shouldn't it be like the embodied
cognition of all of the firm members?
Or how do you get that bi directional
integration of information without the
bottom mattering just as much as the top
here?
This is, like, fuzzy and weird for me.
Tyler: Well, I think at one level
organization, it's each member's
individual dopamine receptors and
everything, right?
But then at the next level, you can
abstract out of way and say, maybe it's
like the response to financing, maybe
having more access to venture capital
funding, for example, is a way of
motivating action for an organization or
visitor growth.
On a landing page, it's like the signal
of, like, hey, you're going in the right
direction.
Double down here and keep moving or keep
exploring.
So that's maybe how I would think of it
at an organizational level in a way that
maybe feels kind of like, at a different
level than just the sum of the dopamine
receptors of all of its members.
Bleu: Yeah, like hearing you on the
gamification metrics for the
organization, like hits on the landing
page, or the number of subscribers, or
the number of viewers, or the number of
Twitter followers.
All those things like we know that are
rewarding us personally with dopamine.
I guess that's like an easy bridge to
cross regarding dopamine and
institutional success or prediction or
minimization.
I think.
Tyler: Well, what I mean by that is a
little bit differently.
It's not like on an individual level, if
you see more hits on your landing page,
that's going to have a dopamine response
with you as an individual.
But I think some of these things, like,
for example, like press coverage or
getting venture capital funding, for
example, those produce systemic changes
in an organization that aren't just
merely about the dopamine response in the
individual.
And that's something that I feel like is
like a higher level change that is harder
to explain.
I'm struggling to come up with the words
from it, but just like when you get a lot
of funding into an organization or a
startup or you start getting traction on
something, it produces a kind of like
social contagion.
I don't know if that's the right word.
That is more than just the sum of its
parts of dopamine changes of its
individuals.
Bleu: Anything else here?
Or we can move on to artificial
intelligence.
So here Bajan says free energy
minimization is a machine logic in its
own right, empowering living as well as
artifactual organisms to optimally resist
entropy.
And this is, I think, a shout out to the
many people who are working on using
active inference in machine learning
instead of reinforcement learning.
So that's kind of great.
And he really talks about the ethics of
that.
What happens when we talk about the
singularity, right?
Like when machines become smarter than
us?
And he says that effectively the
challenge is moving from coding, like
programming, even with active inference.
Right.
So coding to ethics, like how are we
going to ethically program the machines
so that they're not like self driving
cars aren't running over people or
whatever?
So there's the ethics and then to
survival, to human survival, right?
Yeah.
If the machines get to a point where they
don't need us anymore, why should they
follow the ethics that we've programmed
into them, I guess.
Daniel: Anil Seth, this was a very
interesting section.
First we could imagine a kind of trolley
car problem with some organization and
some people, and eventually the kind of
decidability that's going to have to come
into play there.
And the other provocative aspect in this,
from coding to ethics to survival, is we
often hear you can't get an ought from an
Is, so no amount of mechanic definition
is going to result in an ethical
imperative.
Can't get an ought from an Is.
And that kind of describes this coatings
to ethics difficulty.
You can't really get an Ethic just from
how something is encoded.
But in a way, survival is being proposed
as a post ethical imperative of first
principles.
We couldn't necessarily go from Is to
ought, but we can go from Is through
ought back to Is, which is survival.
And so it kind of reinstinuates a type of
first principle ethic, more like a work
ethic than like a moral ethic.
But that opens up a lot of questions
about what kinds of ethics are of what
statuses under or after the survival
imperative.
Tyler: Yeah, it's interesting because I
think with Active Inference lab or free
energy governance specifically, there are
two ways where I think it's interesting.
One level is like, thinking about an
organization as an organism where it's
like, independent of my human experience
of that organism, of what makes this
organism survive.
And then I think the reason why I care
about it the most, which is my own human
experience of how meaning is created for
me in an organization.
And I think ultimately that's personally,
at least, what I care about the most.
And then when I think about AI, I'm like,
okay, well, even if you have an embedded
AI in your system, if it doesn't mean
something personally to the humans in
that organization, I don't really care,
even if it makes the organization survive
more likely to survive.
So it's just like, interesting, these two
different takes of like, okay, even if it
makes the organization more likely to
survive, why do I care if that isn't
meaningful to me as a human in that
organization?
Not sure if that makes sense.
Bleu: Yeah.
So then Bajan also says first order
principles such as AI's free Energy
Minimization will lay the foundation for
governance models to increasingly self
organize.
So I think that this is very meta.
It's like how Daniel was saying we go
from coding to ethics to survival.
I think maybe ethics is like the fog
between coding and survival, where free
Energy Minimization is about persistence
and can be used in coding and will lay
the foundation for governance models to
increasingly self organized.
So like, self organization based on free
energy minimization.
I guess the section was interesting and I
do think that there's like, Pajama super
excited about AI and we got a long way to
go.
We'll get there.
It's not impossible.
It's just going to take some time, I
think.
Any other thoughts here in artificial
intelligence?
I mean, I have lots of other thoughts
here, but I think getting Bashan's
perspective will be really fun.
Tyler: Yeah, I think the thing I really
am not quite understanding here is the
explainability piece, and I think I was
trying to mention this earlier.
If you have an AI that's like, bubbling
up insights about your organization
saying like, hey, this is what's going
on, or this is the right answer of what
you should do in this situation, but it
isn't understood by the people in that
organization.
Does it even matter?
And is that what Bajan means by
explainability?
Right.
Even if AI gives you the right answer,
but it isn't understood and integrated
into the people in the organization, is
that AI actually useful in that
organization?
And that's like the tension I've been
grappling with here and I don't quite
understand.
And he talks about explainability of
predictions.
I'm not sure if that's exactly what he's
talking about or not, but it's a good
question for Bajan for sure.
Bleu: And then the last section for
future development is the board
capabilities developmental paths.
So he says, indeed, the board is
ultimately responsible for anticipating
the firm's future capability
constellation, including that of the
board itself, to sustainably succeed with
continuous strategic renewal.
However, to avoid the cognitive traps
related to individual board profiles that
Layman and Wallin identified, we must
study the cognitive microfoundations of
capability development at the board
level.
To date, this area represents a void in
both strategy and governance research.
So I thought that this was cool,
especially with respect to active
inference lab institute, like as we are
fleshing out our own board and the board
decides what this and future boards will
be capable of doing now and forever, and
all this stuff can be changed with
approval of the board.
Right?
So I think that I like this capability
constellation phrase.
I thought that that was kind of neat
because there's a lot of little sub
capabilities within the board, like
there's committees and this and that, and
everybody can do or take care of many
different things, or what don't we want
the board to do?
The possibilities are pretty endless and
expansive, but what is purposeful and
what will gain the most bang for the buck
in terms of what should the board focus
on?
That's kind of crazy.
And then he outlined a little bit of
these cognitive traps, but I didn't go
too far into them here.
Do you guys have anything here on board
capabilities?
Oh, so this, so I did go actually a
little bit into them.
So what capabilities are required at the
level of the individual board member when
the necessary firm capabilities are not
yet developed?
And so, as Bajan is thinking about this,
he goes to this theory U, which I had
never heard of before.
And so he outlines three of the
principles developed in this theory U.
And it looks like that there's quite a
few, but he talked about what are the
capabilities required at the board member
level when we're defining the firm
capabilities, like the board capabilities
for now and forever.
And so these I really liked.
So he says number nine, practice
principle number nine is what it is.
Practice deep listening and dialogue.
Connect with your mind and heart wide
open when connecting to other people and
contact.
Open up all four channels of listening.
Listen from what you know, from what
surprises you, from the whole and from
what you sense wants to emerge, the
emerging whole.
And I really like this like four
different ways of listening, something
that we don't always think about.
We just listen.
And we listen in one way.
I listened.
I heard this.
But when you're looking at listening in
different aspects, it's different,
right?
Like, listening from what surprises you?
Can you listen to it four times and
pretend like you don't know anything?
Pretend like, how does this relate to
what you already know?
I thought that this was really nice.
I don't know if you guys have if you were
excited about it as I was as excited or I
can read collective sense making next.
Or maybe Tyler wants to read collective
sense making.
Tyler: Yes.
I was just going to say I really love the
convergence of new AG and corporate
governance literature.
Kind of converging in reenergy
governance.
It's wonderful.
All right, so number ten collective sense
making.
So use social presencing, theater and
embodied knowing.
So whatever process you use to make sense
of the learning journey, what matters
most is that you pay disciplined
attention to all the voices and
manifestations of the field.
Paying disciplined attention means that
you are intentionally holding back all
inclinations to mix your own
interpretations or solutions.
Just spend all that because you want the
data of the field to speak for you.
The field cannot speak to you if your
mind is too busy.
Bleu: So that was also cool.
But the data of the field cannot speak to
you if your mind is too busy expressing
opinions and proposing solutions.
Oh, that cuts to the core.
Yeah, sorry, I guess I cut that off.
And then whatever.
My slide making capabilities were
subpar.
And then the last principle is principle
22.
I'm like, now I'm like, I want to read
this theory.
You like, what is this all about?
I'm totally interested in learning more
about these principles.
Number 22 is create enabling
infrastructures that allow the system to
sense and see itself.
And he quotes, making the system sense
and see itself can change the
coordination dynamics among the players
in a field, moving them toward ecosystem
awareness.
As traditional governance models are
increasingly uprooted in a discontinuous
world, there is not only a need for a new
governance project, but correspondingly
new board capabilities, developmental
paths, specifically, duality management
as a dynamic board capability demands
dedicated research.
And that duality management, just to
remind everyone, is like financial and
strategic control.
So it's like both of those things, not
one or the other.
They both work together.
Then we can go into chapter 13.
Or if you guys have more thoughts about
this, these theory you principles.
No, we can go into this.
Chapter 13.
Tyler, do you want to read this portion
of the abstract?
Tyler: For us, the classical cause effect
determinism upon which the paradigm of
strategy management as well as governance
research has been built, is uprooted.
Baparian academics relentless pursuit of
empirically establishing, qualifying, and
then falsifying mechanistic cause and
effective relationships is struggling to
inspire the business community, which is
itself wriggling too often with the self
inflicted limitations of its own, of its
very world models.
Together, academia and practice are
challenged to reconnect organizing to
that self evidencing dimension of the
universe's information system.
Fpg is as valid for business
organizations as it is for political
contracts, or for that matter, navigating
geopolitical dislocations and debt cycle
disruptions.
Bleu: Thank you.
And I'll read this last piece.
It says, any organism that suffers from
one top down, bottom up hierarchical
disconnectivity and a top down dominance
of supervised content prescriptions.
Two, an urge to adapt to the outer world
emit an incapacity for an active
inference.
And three, the nonexistence of both a
timeless depurpose as well as
medicapabilities is naturally entropy
bound.
In the absence of a generative Bayesian
model, we become incapacitated.
Indeed, camping on seesaws is the
categorical imperative of survival
pursuing self organization.
Organization as a means, not an end.
It is right here where the fundamental
difference between traditional corporate
governance and free energy governance
models lie.
Free energy governance sees the informal
organization as organizing, manifests
itself as a self organizing generative
model operating as a whole, within and
without the firm, embracing self
organization as a self evidencing
universal information system.
And so he makes like I just pulled out
several claims that he made in this
chapter and a couple of little summary
sections, because this is like the
official summary.
He says, Together, academia and practice
are challenged to reconnect organizing to
that self organizing or self evidencing
dimension inherent of the universe's
information system to purposefully
create, extend or modify the firm's
resource base.
And that's a quote from Health Fed, et
al.
And he says, to thrive and survive
purposeful behavior is one of life's
defining features, but it is only
possible if living systems operate as a
whole.
It is only by managing information that
the cell can impose order on the extreme
complexity of its operations and
therefore fulfill its ultimate purpose of
staying alive and reproducing.
And this is a quote from Nurse 2020.
And I don't know, this is so hard because
I'll always go back to Mike Levin's
beautiful explanation of the constraints
imposed by the larger system on a smaller
system.
Because a cell's ultimate purpose is not
staying alive, reproducing.
In fact, if it's one cell, sure, but in a
multicellular organism, some cells, like
the purpose of the cell, is to die.
We all start off with webbing between the
fingers, and that webbing is cells.
And then that webbing goes away.
So that cell, in the construction of our
existence and our morphology, its purpose
is to die.
So I guess, like we were talking about
MNA earlier, the purpose of the smaller
firm that gets subsumed by a larger firm
is also to die or become incorporated or
to somehow integrate with the current
larger firm.
And so these constraints, I don't know.
So the nested hierarchical levels, each
top level or each larger level constrains
the function of the inner level and also
that information.
Sorry, I have to just say that because
otherwise staying alive and reproducing
is not the purpose of self.
Sorry, I don't know if you guys have
thought to move on.
Bijean says free energy as an information
theoretic rather than thermodynamic
measure, is uniquely positioned to
measure and guide a firm's survivability
as a self organizing information as well
as belief system.
And he quotes this book from Lindsay
2021.
Daniel, have you read this?
I haven't read it, but it's like a frison
memoir, I guess.
He says Friston recalls a thought he had
as a teenager.
There must be a way of understanding
everything by starting from nothing.
If I'm only allowed to start off with one
point in the entire universe, can I
derive everything else I need from that?
In friskin's world, the free energy
principle is now the nearly nothing that
can explain almost everything.
I like this quote from this book.
And also, I've got to go read it now.
I don't know if it's a frison memoir or
maybe it's just an interview or like a
long article or something like that, but
I haven't read it.
But it's like someone else giving a
detail of Kristen's life and ideas, I
guess.
I don't know if you guys have thoughts
here.
No.
Yes.
Okay.
I just want to just call out.
We just talked about very early on, maybe
it was like the fourth video we did talk
about.
What are we talking about?
Thermodynamic versus information
theoretic free energy.
Go back because we really did get into
that.
So if you're going, what are they talking
about?
We did talk about that quite a bit in one
of the early videos.
So now might be a good time to just
refresh your memory that we did detail
that.
So if that's looking weird to you, go get
a refresher.
Okay.
And then claim here, in summary, the
inferential discovery of informational
dissonance as an error minimizing source
for optimizing the accuracy of posterior
beliefs rather than explaining dissonance
away is essential to firm survival in
discontinuous environments.
And I like this informational dissonance
part.
This was like a couple videos ago.
Not that not that far in the past, but
yeah.
So this brought up the initial
communication question for Bajan.
Does everybody need to know everything
all of the time and also your information
getting updated with the outside
information to resolve the dissonance.
Anyway, there's that.
Do you get some thoughts here?
All right, I'm going to make somebody
else read these because I'm tired of
talking, tired of hearing myself talk.
Tyler, do you want to do this?
This is the building blocks of an active
inference.
So this is a nice little summary recap of
what we've learned so far.
Tyler: All right.
Building blocks of active inference lab.
So one is the four states that's active
action, sensory perception, internal firm
resources, and external the.
Hidden unknowns.
Two one internal external Markovian
boundary the site where actions upon
hidden states generate outcomes that feed
in circular causality our perception and
allow the precision enhancing updating of
prior beliefs.
Predictions three one first order
principle free energy minimization as a
measure of minimizing equivocally error
and uncertainty I.
E.
The divergence between predictions, prior
beliefs and outcomes posterior beliefs.
Eventually, everything becomes
measurable.
Bleu: Thank you.
Yeah.
And so Bijean makes this claim that once
managers start approaching exploration in
the form of an active inference linking
in circular causality all four states
conditioned by the Markov blanket and
governance by free energy minimization,
we can straightaway see that success and
exploration is critically determined by
the level of sophistication of a few
things.
First, prediction models a self
evidencing eco niche model that connects
corporate purpose with the very
predictions the firm stipulates.
Second, the bounded set of external
states that the firm decides to act upon
to bottom up, sample the world and test
hypotheses with the least required
computational resource investment.
And third, belief updating resulting from
the consequences posterior beliefs that
the firm's actions generate.
And so this was also, like a nice little
summary section, I thought, and he
continues to say it is now self evident
to appreciate that action is central to
perception.
More importantly, the firm's generative
model and actions control ambiguity and
uncertainty.
The firm's generative model is the firm's
eco niche.
The firm is more in control than it
traditionally resists to believe.
The perception of uncertainty is after
observer I.
E.
Firm specific.
And I did like that real uncertainty
versus the perception of uncertainty.
And when we're talking about embodied,
enacted, extended cognition, it's all
about your perception of uncertainty
versus actual uncertainty.
So unless you can count cards, you're
uncertain of like if you're playing
blackjack, you don't you don't know what
your chances are of getting 21.
But if you can count cards, that's just
one example.
You're less uncertain if it's a single
deck blackjack, you're less uncertain as
to what are the possibilities as the game
continues to unfold.
Daniel: It's also interesting there with
the kind of Declaration of Independence
like self evident appreciation that
reflects the real bright line between
passive inference and active inference.
And it's like that claim does one agree
or disagree?
And then if they did agree, then they
have already seen their own eye movement
and decision to seek out this information
as central to their perception of that
expression.
So it kind of serves as like a co on of
self evidencing.
And then there are some downstream
implications.
For example, one that he attacks many
times throughout is that the external
world is not uncertain.
There's not uncertainty in the
commodities market.
There's an observer dependent uncertainty
about external states and about action
selection.
Active Inference Lab is a generic family
of strategies for jointly resolving
uncertainty about external states and
actions that bring alignment aka provide
pragmatic value.
So many of those implications of feg are
downstream of the acceptance or
acknowledgment that action is central to
perception.
Bleu: Very nice.
Thank you.
Okay, so he lists these requirements for
outperformance and survival.
Tyler, do you want to read these for me?
Tyler: Yes.
All right.
One, a timeless deep purpose.
Two generative top down, bottom up,
prediction error, minimization form of
free energy minimizing active inference
lab.
Three principled values and aspirations
determining go niche prosperity and
sustainability.
If all three elements are articulated in
simple explainable, Lagrange and
communicated to all members within and
beyond the firm's boundaries, then the
firm's long term prospects will be
sustainably enhanced in form of self
organizing generative model.
The board of directors, rather than
executive leadership only, must ensure
that those elements come to life and more
importantly, stay alive.
Bleu: Thanks.
Sorry.
So this goes back to, like, we were
talking about purpose earlier.
Where does purpose come from?
Who decides what the purpose is?
So it was more talked about, I think, a
lot in this chapter.
And we've also talked about it before
through the book.
So this is a nice little wrap up
section.
And then Bijean goes on to make the claim
that free organization okay.
I've said organization so many times.
I think if I were to count, like, I
probably have said the word organization
like a thousand times in this live
stream.
Maybe not, maybe 150.
Energy governance is as valid for
business organizations as it is for
political constructs, or for that matter,
navigating geopolitical dislocations and
debt cycle disruptions.
Any organism that suffers from a one top
down, bottom up disconnectivity.
Two top down dominance of ideological and
supervised content prescriptions.
Three, dominant logic to adapt to the
outer world amid a self inflicted
incapacity for an active inference.
And not least, four, non existence of a
timeless purpose, as well as
medicabilities such as listening to what
wants to emerge in the web of random
interactions and observing the observer
is naturally entropy bound and
incapacitated to navigate macro
disruptions.
So he gives that recipe for survival and
outperformance here in the last
requirements for outperformance and
survival.
So I think that those are just like the
three.
Those are just like the inverse
statements of each other, like, this is
what we need, this is what we can't
have.
So that's a nice way to wrap up how free
energy governance will contribute to the
firm's outperformance and survival in the
world, competing with other firms and
such.
Do you guys have any thoughts here?
Good.
Okay.
And then I just pulled this final quote
out, and we kind of alluded to this
earlier.
It says, does the uncertainty that human
space come from the inherent instability
of the human landscape or from the
perceptions and belief systems that we
have about the human environment?
And this is kind of nice.
What is it that's unstable?
Where is the uncertainty?
Is the uncertainty in our perception or
is it in the world somewhere?
So I don't know.
This is a nice thing to think about, and
in resolving that uncertainty through
action, I think, gets to kind of the core
of free energy governance here at the end
of the book.
Thanks for listening.
I don't know if you guys have any final
thoughts on any of the content presented
here in these two chapters or on the book
overall or questions that are brewing
through your mind.
Nothing like that.
All right.
We're quick through the concluding
sections, and we look forward to having
an open discussion with the author in a
few weeks, as well as other participants
who have been keeping up with the
content.
So thanks, guys.
Daniel: Thank you, Tyler.
Thank you.
Bleu farewell.